right in simplified exponential form and
we have a product of a bunch of things
here six times seven times six times
nine times two to the fourth times two
times six squared times nine so a good
place to start is just group the things
that are of the same base and then maybe
we can combine their exponents and then
let's see if we can simplify it from
there and let's just go in order of the
bases so let's start with the two so we
have a two to the fourth here and then
we have times two you could do that as
times two to the first if you like so
let me write that there so we have two
to the fourth
times two i'll just rewrite it as two to
the first so we did our twos the next
largest number or the next largest base
is
the sixes or are the sixes we have a six
right there so times already the six to
the first
times another six
or times another six to the first right
there and then we have a six squared
over here so times six squared i'm
really just rearranging this this
product out here then the next number
that we have here the next largest one
we have a seven we only have one seven
there so we'll just write
times
seven and then finally we have a couple
of nines we have a couple of nines right
there we have one nine there so times
i'll do it right as it's nine to the one
and then we have another nine times nine
to the one or we could just write that
as nine times nine
now let's merge the bases or let's learn
to merge the products of these bases
raised to different exponents you have 2
to the first 2 to the 4th power times 2
to the first power this is going to be
the same thing as 2 to the 4 plus one
power or two to the fifth power
then you have your sixes
so six to the first times six to the
first times six squared is the same
thing as
six to the one plus one plus two or six
to the fourth power
then we have that seven there nothing
really you can do to simplify that
times that seven and then we have a nine
times a nine which is nine squared or
you could think about it as nine to the
first times nine to the first add the
exponents 9 squared
so times 9 squared
so depending on how you want to do this
problem the people actually wrote this
problem this is what they wanted they
viewed this as simplified exponential
form we've combined the same bases
raised to different powers so you could
stop here
but if you really want to get it down to
kind of the real simplest form what you
could essentially do is break everything
down into their prime factors and then
have those raised to exponents and then
merge them even more let's let me show
you what i'm talking about so the six to
the fourth here let me let me keep it
the same color code so we have the two
to the fifth let me just write that
there
but the six to the fourth i could
rewrite six i can rewrite six as two
times three
to the fourth the six to the fourth is
the exact same thing as that
then we have the times seven
then we have the 9 squared but 9 we can
rewrite we can write 9 as 3 squared and
all of that squared all i read all i did
here is i rewrote the 6 is 2 times 3 and
i rewrote the 9 as 3 times 3 or is 3
squared
now let me just i want to keep the color
codes the same way so we have the 2 to
the 5th
times now what's 2 times 3 to the 4th
well here's an exponent property if you
take the product of two things and it's
two of power that's the same thing as
two to the fourth
times three to the fourth
and then you have this seven here
times seven
so i essentially just raised both of
these guys to the fourth because this
their product is being raised to the
fourth power and then you have times 3
squared but you have 3 squared and then
that squared so it's going to be to 3 to
the 2 times 2 power so times
3 to the fourth so now we have more
bases we can merge we have these we have
these twos here
two to the fifth times two to the fourth
what's that well that's two to the five
plus four that's two to the ninth power
then you have your threes over here let
me do that in green
you have three to the fourth and three
to the fourth what's that going to be
that's going to be times 3 to the 4 plus
4th power or 3 to the 8th power and then
finally you have this 7 sitting over
there
so if you really wanted to break things
down into their prime factors and have
and kind of have the least bases here
this is you could view this as even a
more simplified exponential form than
what the the question writers originally
wanted
so you could get down all the way to two
to the ninth times three to the eighth
times seven which is the same thing as
that which is the exact same thing as
that